okay so let's get into now an interview
that is like nothing i have ever seen in
the united states this is an interview
in which donald trump
finally out of his bunker of media
isolation after losing to joe biden has
started doing media again
on thanksgiving he took some questions
from reporters which we will get to but
i'm starting here
with his interview yesterday morning on
fox news with maria bartiromo this
interview is indistinguishable from a
north korean
state media reporter maria bartiromo
went along with donald trump's obvious
lies with the same credulity
as those north korean state media
anchors when they used to report
oh kim jong-il got a hole-in-one on all
18
holes kim jong-un doesn't defecate right
i mean it's it's like that what maria
bartoromo does here
trump told endless lie after lie many of
them completely corrosive to our
democracy
and she went along with every single one
and then just to add insult to injury
or maybe better said to add a cartoonish
element to this
donald trump insisted multiple times
that it was massive dumps that led him
to lose the election which is
just like on another level altogether
from from the standpoint of comedy
so let's get right into it because we do
have so much to get to
uh check this out combining here the sir
routine with this new massive dumps meme
and what happened if you watched the
election i was called by the biggest
people
saying congratulations political people
congratulations sir you just won the
election
it was 10 o'clock and you looked at the
numbers and i'm sure you felt
that way this election was over and then
they did
dumps they call them dumps big massive
dumps
in michigan and pennsylvania
it's it's just beyond parody massive
dumps cost him the election huge dumps
were happening all over the country
as the results were coming in what is
going on here we are a laughingstock and
in this
in this next clip donald trump pushes
completely baseless
voter fraud conspiracies and if you're
watching
uh pay special attention to the looks on
maria bartoromo's face she's acting
like when trump says maybe the fbi was
involved
she reacts as if wow the fbi is really
involved in this
this is total fraud and how the fbi and
department of justice i don't know maybe
they're involved
but how people are allowed to get away
from this stuff with this stuff is
unbelievable
this election was rigged this election
was a total fraud and it continues to be
as they hide and the problem we have we
go to judges and
people don't want to get involved what
trump means there
by we go to judges and they don't want
to get involved what he means is
judges look at our so-called evidence
and find it completely lacking in merit
that's actually what's going on
here is trump just straight up saying
the popular vote numbers are wrong
ballot boxes and they use covid as a
means
to stuff the ballot boxes joe biden
did not get 16 million more votes than
barack
hussein obama he didn't get it joe biden
did not get
14 million more votes than hillary
clinton and by the way
he didn't beat obama in the black
communities you go to some of these
communities where obama
is very very popular and he beats him in
some of these communities
but all throughout the rest of the
united states
in a black community he does he does
actually poorly he doesn't do very well
this one should not surprise any of us
remember that donald trump
still hasn't accepted the results of the
popular vote from 2016.
that was an election that made trump
president and so
as we've been saying for months
obviously trump was never going to
accept the 2020 popular vote results
and he's not and then maria bartoromo
goes
full propaganda actor she says listen
if you don't consider the electoral
votes of the contested swing states
you win mr president critical part of
this story mr president but if you take
out the contested swing states electoral
votes
you're back down to president trump
having
232 electoral votes and joe biden having
227
that is if you strip out the six states
with the legal challenges so
is the thinking here that because of the
various ballot issues
that the supreme court will rule that
the vote is tainted
and that will mean that they have to
take votes away from biden and not
certify
is that the thinking and secondly what's
your timing on this mr president
because we've got some notable election
dates here that i want to ask you
this reminds me of the old internet
viral phrase
if my grandmother had wheels instead of
legs
she would be a bicycle the point is
that's not the situation swing states
are part of the country
swing states have not been shown to have
had fraudulent results
the swing states merely count like any
others
you don't get to not count them because
the results are inconvenient
and maria bartoromo really outdoing
herself
here and um trump then goes on
completely delusionally to talk about
assertions of
hundreds of thousands of votes that are
just fraud and
anything to not admit he simply lost the
election and quite decisively
but we actually have thousands of votes
in some cases hundreds of thousands of
votes
more than we need in every swing state
that we're talking about
so then here comes in maria bartoromo
on a bizarre rant and she says this is
all
disgusting mr president this is
disgusting
and we cannot allow america's election
to be
corrupted we cannot so you believe you
can prove that the commute
computers can circumvent any controls
that are in place
and before we leave the subject of
durham not only is maria making no sense
why is she screaming the entire
interview it's really bizarre
and this finally starts to wind down and
maria bartoromo's interview ends
with trump saying it's statistically
impossible
what happened and maria bartoromo
responds
by saying it's all quite extraordinary
mr president
they say it's statistically impossible i
led the charge
we won state houses we won congress we
won the senate
and i lost they say it's statistically
impossible
for that to happen it's it's all quite
extraordinary mr president we want to
thank you so much for joining me today
and thank you for your work
yes all quite extraordinary telling
obvious lies
which is what not only what trump is
doing but what maria does
this is now right-wing virtue signaling
they decry so-called virtue signaling on
the left
to signal that you're part of what i
would call right think
meaning right has two meanings correct
and right wing
you have to keep telling lies that most
people now recognize as lies
and this is not only corrosive to
democracy
it's a global embarrassment and we're
going to deal with that embarrassment
piece on the friday show this week
it is a complete and total global shame
that is taking place here and
unfortunately this was not the only such
event over the holiday weekend we now
have to get to how it went down
when donald trump took questions from
reporters on thanksgiving day
for the first time since the election
our sponsor purevpn is having a huge
black friday sale
right now they're giving you 88 office
subscription
which comes out to only a little over a
dollar a month
purevpn makes you anonymous when you're
browsing online and you can trust them
because they're the
only vpn in the industry with an
always-on
third-party audit to verify that your
internet activity
is not being logged by hiding your ip
address purevpn keeps you safe
from hackers and prevents you from being
spied on by your internet service
provider
social media companies and even
government surveillance
it also lets you watch shows and movies
that aren't available in your country
purevpn is super fast you can use it on
all of your devices
and i can tell you firsthand the app is
really easy to use
and they have 6500 servers across the
world which is more than any other vpn
in the industry everyone should be using
a vpn when connecting to the internet
and now is the perfect time to start
because purevpn is giving you an 88
discount on a subscription which comes
out to only a little over
a dollar a month go to davidpakman.com
purevpn the link is underneath the video